foreign
what's going on there citizens of the
reject Nation happy Halloween to all of
you John got our Halloween plans uh you
know maybe go uh walk around amongst the
people trick-or-treating and just soak
up the old time Vibe what about you
what I got from that is you're gonna
walk around a bunch of little kids
that's right that's me a grown man I
walk around children my best friends are
children
um
yep
well
document this is evident guys we got
some news to talk about if you can
please go ahead treat us with that like
button so uh first thing we got to talk
about right here is Witcher season four
is gonna suck right am I right yeah it's
gonna suck
um no let's not talk about that anyway
oh Liam what we got to talk about is how
producer Nate Moore of uh the Marvel
Cinematic Universe what he was talking
about recently with a channel called
phase zero he was asked about the Doctor
Doom rumors of Doctor Doom appearing in
Black Panther wakanda forever I know
some people they might consider this a
spoiler the fact that we are here to say
it's not really a spoiler but I I guess
for what isn't there yeah Dr Doom from
the screening that we saw he's not in
the film Nate Moore what he decided to
do was go ahead and explain why Dr Doom
wasn't featured in it and what he said
was I get why and he's such a great
character and the world of Liberia is so
fantastic but once we decided that Namor
is the antagonist that was always going
to be the focus he said that it's very
emotional Channel and that the weight of
the movie is a bit different we felt the
ending of the film was so poetic to then
go back and say hey there's a tag at the
end of the credits felt a little
disingenuous tonally from what we were
doing I remember when this movie ended
now I know our review is not out there
yet because embargo hasn't lifted for it
and I still got to edit it's a long
review I got to cut it down but I
remember when the credits started
rolling and I was sitting next to our
Buddy Aaron who you might have seen in
those uh Spider-Man no way home trailer
reactions with us and I was sitting next
to him and I was just quiet for a few
minutes I wasn't like chit chatting with
anyone about the film right when it was
done and I remember just leaning forward
and turning to him and going
it just feels like you'd be a little
inappropriate if Dr Doom showed up at
the very end of this film this movie is
so different this movie without going
into anything specific whatsoever while
it's a massive film it's a big movie it
feels very focused and personal in
regards to what it's thematically
touching on that to then have a Doctor
Doom post-credits scene just wouldn't
Vibe personally with me like it was
weird because prior to watching this
movie I hadn't heard the rumors like all
of you that Doctor Doom might be in this
movie he might be in the post-critic
scene he might explain some stuff yada
yada and there's a couple of things that
might be an Easter egg to Doctor Doom
nothing really overt and I've heard the
the speculation that maybe it is still
there but they're just waiting for the
actual release before they slap it on to
the to the film they didn't want it to
come out for early screenings or
whatever which I respect if that's the
case but from Where I Stood I was really
happy there was not a post-credit scene
for some other movie to come or
something bigger down the road because
that's a big part of what made the
mid-credit scene just hit home so much
harder what left me with such an
emotional impact after the film was done
that it was just all about the movie and
not anything to do with what the future
is and I think having a Doctor Doom
thing would have actually undercut The
Experience weirdly enough I don't know I
might change my tune if if it happens to
come out and it happens to work and it
happens to be great maybe but I I don't
see a scenario where it honestly does
even though I expect Dr Doom to come in
the future of the MCU I personally was
really happy with the choice and I
completely agree with everything Nate
Moore said as to why there wasn't a
Doctor Doom featured here yeah no I
couldn't agree with either of you more
and I feel like this is pretty
definitive given these quotes here like
yeah they could still tack something on
for the theatrical release but I feel
like this is a pretty solid statement of
their intent and being that this is the
end of phase four and being that this is
such an important singular movie beyond
the implications of just in Universe MCU
it does feel a bit I guess disingenuous
is a good word for it to then yeah Point
your attention to something else I
wouldn't at all be surprised though if
there are clues that they will then
utilize later on I feel like this movie
will still exist within the Continuum
and the interconnectivity of the MCU but
that's not the point of why we're here
and yeah Namor and everything with
telecon is in need of so much fleshing
out and so much introduction and so much
Focus that I feel like it was wise of
them I mean even if we didn't have all
the circumstances with Chadwick Boseman
I feel like it would still overshadow
most everything about the movie if you
brought in Dr Doom confirmed that
involvement confirmed this connectivity
to the upcoming Fantastic Four in a very
explicit kind of way yeah it just seems
like for what this movie needs to
achieve and for the emotionality of it
for the real lived experience that is
being brought into this picture uh yeah
there's just nothing that Dr Doom would
complement about that in any kind of
emotional or contextual way other than
giving you like a nerd rush and I feel
like of all the MCU movies this is not
the one where you need a big sort of ah
like geek out nerd Rush thing to point
to because this is also one of their
better movies in general and I feel like
they're confident enough to let it stand
on those legs as well and so yeah I
don't think not that Dr Doom is a bell
and a whistle but at the same time I
feel like in this experience it would
feel that way if they were to then you
know kind of at random at the end
without any prompting go he's down there
though he's he's pulling strings and I
think given what a lot of the
speculation has been not that they
couldn't come in with some kind of
separate motive or separate means of
incorporating it but I feel like to
really give the conflict that this movie
is trying to deal with its Credence I I
think it's appropriate to yeah save
Doctor Doom because we all know he's
coming and what I would also add to it
is you know as much as I'm going to be a
massive hypocrite right now is if we had
not seen the an early screening of it
we'd be covering all the clips and
trailers we'd be doing all that like I I
know for sure we'd be doing all that hey
buddy no right um You Want Doctor Doom
after seeing the movie I'm glad that
there's so much we did not cover and now
they're releasing all these clips and
such and I know I probably wouldn't make
much of a difference being saying this
but I would I would avoid all that
honestly like there was so much I did
not know was in this film and I would I
I think it makes for just a much better
and more rewarding experience all around
with regards to Dr Doom not having a
post credit scene for that to me it's
kind of akin to in a way Avengers end
game how there wasn't a post-credit
scene for that think about it like this
that was a fictional character Iron
Man's death and and honoring him it's
like let's just focus on the on the
grief of Iron Man here have the clinging
sound going on like let's just keep it
simple like that no post-credits scene
and now you have a fictional character
t'challa is dead but then the real life
actor Chadwick Boseman is dead so you're
dealing with a lot of things
thematically that are very heavy and I I
think it is perfect to not have that
post credit scene but the mid credit
scene is wonderful if it hasn't been
ruined for you thank God because it is a
wonderful mid credit scene all right
guys well what do you think are you
still pissed that Dr dooman is in here
leave your thoughts down below subscribe
click that notification Bell and hey
um go ahead and we'll have a have a
happy Halloween
um all right so just got out of
black panther wakanda forever
we're about to shoot our just watched
discussion
and uh
yeah that
I'll say is that was so powerful and
I got we got a lot to talk about but
yeah I thought it was
so beautiful it was freaking powerful